hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
ultimativen weihnachts quiz das mir
davon negativ egal und das ist kelly
fahren wie er ist bin ich die ultimative
weihnachts fanatikerin und die beiden
halt nicht so du wirst voller weihnachts
und da ich ja schon super weihnachtlich
angezogen bin und die beiden versucht
haben durch mehr sein
gibt's noch accessoires für übrigens
gesagt sein dass wir brauchen wir
unbedingt eine kannst du dich noch
kaufen weil ist es hat doch jeder zu
hause
es gibt zehn fragen für jede richtig
beantwortete frage gibt es einen
zimtstern und wer am ende die meisten
standard hat gewonnen und ist vielleicht
ein wenig so wie ich ein ultimativer
weihnachts könig ich habe auch 22 basa
für euch da müsste jetzt sagen ihr dürft
nicht gucken
naja ok linke oder rechte hand links die
flöte des harry potter ist
flöte spielen ich will euch nicht
instrumente geben wollen
fast wie ackermann
kommen wir zur allerersten fragen auf
twitter schon der weihnachtsmann hat ja
rentiere form das war die falsche keine
antwort der weihnachtsmann hat ja
rentiere nennt abwechselnd jeweils ein
rentier wurde dann ein wahres arbeit
dann war ich einfach ich hab gesagt es
war richtig sie hat sich dann für die
anderen bringt hier ist ein nhl ich mein
bespricht alles harry goad genial neben
rudolf gibt es noch besser dancer
prenzlauer [ __ ] konkret cupid donner
und blitzen [ __ ] bewusste fixen
sie kennt kommen wir zur frage nummer
zwei und zwar schicken kinder in
deutschland briefe an dörfer die die
post zum weihnachtsmann bringen
bezwingen sind quasi die poststation des
weihnachtsmannes nenn mir ein dorf gibt
es mehrere gibt mehrere in deutschland
in deutschland da können die generäle
posten schicken
andorf absolut keine ahnung warum fangen
alle mit himmel an das dorf nicht dabei
himmelsberg hitzfeld bereich mit schlamm
mit 40 es nicht mehr reicht es kein dorf
doch das ist ein deutsches dorf und den
weihnachtsmann gibt es ja schon etwas
länger aber wer hat ihn wirklich bezahlt
gemacht
coca cola ein stern
ich denke nicht
wer zwischen du ja so schlagen kann
nicht möglich ab wann fängt man seine
weihnachts deko wieder ab nach neuer
sechser januar einstellen wieso jetzt
kommt die bundes frage wieso am sechsten
januar 8
weil es genau einen monat nach nikolaus
ist
januar sind diese ganzen die die leute
wie dem christkind die sachen sind
diesen gegangen
sie sind gekommen
ich habe gesagt
frage nummer die fragen so wie sie alle
sind ja im jahr 1993 geboren
richtig welcher wochentag war der erste
heiligabend in wir erlebt haben
alte hasen freitag wichtig
ich hab's schnell ausgebreitet und kommt
als drei jahre zurück
wer jetzt das ist keine frage nummer 7
das mag gibt es ja ganz viele leckereien
wir gucken wir haben kein löschen hören
letztens gesehen also schon mal laufen
so bissig wie viele weihnachtsmärkte in
berlin dieses jahr gab 2 und 5 2 5
auf weihnachtsmarkt gibt es ja viele
leckereien sortiert diese folgende nach
wenigsten kalorien und meisten kalorien
aber dafür jede 1 machen wer spart auch
ganz witzig wenn jeder sich das auch auf
schreibt und wir näher dran oder mehr
richtig aber zu einfach dürfen beide
sagen und wer also ihr müsst aber wer
darf als erstes darum erstes gibt hat
weil wir gleich aufzählen da hat dann
den punkt wir müssen propheten meisten
kalorien wenigstens krebs mit dem teller
ein schokoladen apfel oder apfel dann
der bau einer krippe erst der apfel dann
der der das skript und an der baumkuchen
beides falsch er hat kommt der baugrube
mit 213 kalorien
dann kommt der schock opel mit 220
kalorien und dann kommt krebs mit 334
kalorien punkte für euch beide wagen
nummer acht
nennt mir drei berufe die an heiligabend
also nachhaltig abend arbeiten müssen
nein das ist ein feiertag am 25 da wird
nicht der müll abgeholt
die straße hat ein müllmann macht aber
nichts straßenbau beim straßenfest
feuerwehrmänner äpfeln ja nein du hast
mich bei der nächsten frage ich weiß
nicht ob brief viele wiener würstchen
braucht ihr um die also wenn ihr sie
aneinander steckt nämlich länglich um
die durchschnittliche größe eines
tannenbaums zu erreichen zusagen von
hohen preisen
ich sagte mir er dran denn es sind nur
sieben 35 wir müssen wieder besser ist
so lang dass allein eine ganz so lang
da würde ich mich noch nicht 25 cm
durchschnittliches wie ein bisschen und
170 ist kommen wir verletzten frage
frage nummer 10 sankt nikolaus war
ursprünglich ein deutscher
ich hab mir zuerst ein gefallen
wer sein stern
wer seine stelle zuerst aufgegessen hat
hat gewonnen new york ist man auch
schnell und einfach die zusatzfrage
die angeschossenen gemacht